before I knew it it was time to go to
school
this year Frey and call other last names
Frey the frey twins
oh this is kind of cool they introduce
you to all of them
one more time here
oh my gosh dude look at this
all right uh find a seat okay
you already know if we try to sit by
Cassandra no way she's gonna let us
right
no way she would let us actually sit by
her but I'm gonna try it I I feel like I
have to try
let's see if it will if if she'll let us
excuse me may I sit here
this is gonna be a big time no
I knew it
I'm sure there are plenty of other seats
we'll go
all right what about uh Lonnie
is this seat taken she's the artist
right
she's gonna start trying to paint us
right here
it's not but the paint in my bag they're
trying to force you let's see who are
they forcing us to sit by yeah
yeah all right fine Lottie fine
hello oh Ivy okay
[Music]
of course
stormy welcome in
the monster a card next to her
how do I how do I get it are we talking
about like a wizard card I saw the
wizard card yeah
I'm so nervous Jake what's up just got
to Hogwarts nice I probably would have
been there already if not for uh
we had a few issues getting everything
going at the beginning oh here we go
dude
the first years going across the lake
taggard's singing to them
who's that singing
[Music]
welcome to Hogwarts when I first became
headmistress barely full Jake thank you
for the 10 months dude appreciate it
since Voldemort gonna be playing at work
oh this is cool
much like yourselves
the Knights of Hogwarts man
you might think
now to those feeling overwhelmed by the
occasion remember that even Harry Potter
once stood well Harry Potter
oh look at Dumbledore and Snape
difficult very difficult
like would you I would watch a whole
movie in this art style man
I think it'd be so cool
I agree Dan
be akin to your family while you are at
Hogwarts
they will share your triumphs and your
failures is everyone ready yes all right
form a line
after that the Sorting began proper
proper
one by one students were sorted into
their houses
and where is he going it was my turn oh
it didn't tell us
oh my gosh is that is that Sprout back
there
animation when you get the legendary
card is so cool
yeah Dylan
I agree
hmm
where shall I put you
where shall I put you do they ask
questions or do we just pick loyal and
modest all there I see
yep
and just a hint of tenacity excellent
no
shade no what
reconsider
let me take a no I'm not unsure I'm very
sure
interesting yeah it seems totally random
interesting
there we go
is that you
best be sure
I'm sure hat
oh my goodness you have to confirm it so
many times are you sure you want to join
Gryffindor you can only share a dorm
room with students from the same house
yep
foreign
[Applause]
there we go
Gryffindor
grendor oh sorry I kind of stole your
thunder there hat
I think mine sounded more forceful with
feeling you know
didn't seem very excited for me hat I
don't appreciate it
Ivy does anyone know what happened to
Ivan you recreated three new characters
and got all ravenclaws I
I grit oh there's Neville up there dude
I believe a search party is in order it
appears we have lost a student she's
already gotten lost
what no way
I believe Ivy has gone missing
oh dude I didn't realize
I mean I knew a little bit about the
story
okay Ivy probably just took a wrong turn
trouble seems to follow that girl should
I go look for her
I mean yeah should I go look for her she
helped me in the one shop so now it's my
turn to help her
you just found her
if there's still no news of her tomorrow
I'll have to go look for her
I'm exhausted I can't believe so much
has happened
[Music]